hello
it's adele hello
it's me the 33 year old singer made a
rare public appearance for game five of
the nba finals and
girl looked good doing it adele kept it
chic courtside
wearing a black top an oversized
patterned coat black leggings and black
heels
speaking of singing beautiful voice of
adele
and we have to point out how
unbelievably healthy adele's hair
looks absolutely incredible anyway our
girl was
into sports she even waved a little
towel while watching the milwaukee bucks
take on the phoenix suns
as for who she was with she was sitting
next to lebron james's agent
rich paul the two are rumored to be
dating but of course adele hasn't
confirmed anything as the singer is
super private
yeah very even though adele has been
m.i.a she's been sharing her life on the
gram lately
like this pic of hers supporting her
home team following britain's loss in
the euro 2020 soccer championship to
italy
and in may the singer celebrated her
33rd birthday by blessing us with
never-before-seen photos of herself
now i know there's been a lot of chatter
about me just being the host
fans have also been waiting for her
highly anticipated new album
which she addressed when she hosted
saturday night live last fall
my album's not finished and i'm also too
scared to do both
rumor has it the album is coming later
this year and
get this close friend and british
comedian alan carr
revealed to gracia uk he's actually
heard some tracks from the new album
calling the songs he listened to so
amazing
[Music]
so it's just a matter of time until fans
can hear new music
but until then we are living for adele's
rare appearances
[Music]
you